Nikki Haley crumbles like a pumice stone
is that a good analogy I don't know
metaphor
um she was asked three times by Fox News
propagandist Sean Hannity can you tell
me how you differ with Donald Trump on
policy and she was either unable to or
unwilling to do that this is amazing to
see let's get right into it I told you
based on her campaign launch video on um
Tuesday
that Nikki Haley seems to be making the
argument I'm like Trump but younger and
a woman which by the way is identity
politics which we'll talk about later
but it really seems like she's unwilling
or unable to draw any policy
distinctions let's take a look at this
if you had to delineate where say you
and president Trump differ yeah on
issues where would you start
well first let's say in reference to
Whoopi
um you know the thought of me getting
into the race makes the Liberals heads
explode and so I welcome it because it
shows we're doing something right well
but you're not needing to convince any
liberals right now you actually need to
convince Republican voters because
you're in a primary Nikki you know when
it comes to what we're looking at now
listen to the first 20 minutes of your
show look at everything that's wrong in
this country and tell me we don't need
new leadership but the difference is we
need new generational leadership okay so
that's so far all we have is we need a
different generation of people Trump 76
Nikki Haley is I don't know at least 25
years younger than that I would guess
and so so so far the argument is we just
need someone younger we have to leave
the status quo we have to leave this
chaos behind and we've got to start
talking about the future you need a
Washington Outsider that's going to come
in and say it's yes I understand that
families are having to pay more to make
their grocery bill I understand that
they are worried about about their
children who may never get back from
what they lost during covet I understand
the fact that when someone's Factory
leaves town he's worried that his future
went with it so this is verbatim stuff
Trump says so far not a single policy
difference I understand that you should
not have Americans looking up at the sky
and seeing a Chinese spy balloon looking
back at them this is insanity and what
we need remember she's running against
Trump right now not Joe Biden or a lot
of changes first of all we've got too
many politicians in D.C that are past
their Prime we have to have terms so
again just there's too many old people
that's in Congress we need to see
competency tests for any elected
official over the age of 75. we'll get
back to that by the way that's
interesting we've got to stop the
spending addiction that is happening
that is causing inflation to go up and
we need to start realizing that we don't
need our politicians getting on TV and
talking we need the people in DC doing
and we need to spark a fire up on
syndrome and that's what I'm willing to
do and if you are tired of losing
because we've lost the last seven out of
eight popular votes for president we're
doing something wrong if you're tired of
losing then join me I I know you all
notice this but there is not a single
policy difference cited there with
Donald Trump
um this continued Sean Hannity tried it
again
let me go back to my original question
though because yeah which you didn't
answer by the way anybody that is
looking or seeking a nomination it's
you're going to be comparing and
contrasting your policy positions your
views what direction you want to take
the country with your competitors uh
right now there's there's former
president Trump is the only other
candidate for the nomination we expect
many others maybe even Mike Pompeo was
on earlier in the program today where do
you see if you see policy differences
beyond what you mentioned which are
generational differences was what
specific policy areas would you would
you say part with Donald Trump now by
the way good job by Sean Hannity right
well good job because Hannity's already
decided he supports Trump it's Trump's
friend so he's actually doing like what
we might call a real interview
what I am saying is I don't kick
sideways I'm kicking forward Joe Biden
is the president he's the one I'm
running against okay that's code for I'm
not going to criticize Republicans I'm
going to criticize Joe Biden she's not
running against Joe Biden in order to
win against Joe Biden she has to defeat
Trump and what I'm saying is you don't
have to be 80 years old to be president
we don't need to have these same people
going back again we need something new
we need a new generation of Fighters we
need people that understand whether the
American your average American is coming
from and we shouldn't be afraid to fight
for that and that's what I'm willing to
do I'm not going to kick sideways I
don't okay I'm not going to kick
sideways she's not going to criticize
other people that she is running against
and who she has to argue she is a better
choice then that's going to be very
tough to win then now as interesting as
this is
their voters don't care about policy so
it might not you know they sort of are
having the last laugh in the sense that
we look at this and we go she's not
articulating a single policy difference
to Trump I don't know that she has to to
win a republican nomination that's the
sort of sad thing she maybe just does
have to say the stuff that she's saying
I don't know Hannity tried once more I
want to take the country with your
competitors uh right now there's there's
former president Trump is the only other
candidate for the nomination we expect
many others maybe even Mike Pompeo okay
and so I'm realizing that that's the
clip we actually already looked at okay
so multiple attempts there and she
doesn't draw any policy distinctions
this was obvious from the campaign
launch video The Campaign launch video
contained no policy distinctions and
just her saying it's time for a new
generation this is apparently what she's
going to run on plus identity politics
which we will talk about a little bit
later on these clips if you want to
check them out are found on our YouTube
channel youtube.com the davidpackman
show and also the David Pacman Show Now
in Spanish you can find a Spanish
YouTube channel at davidpackman.com
Spanish
one of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zipx toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 with the
code pacman10 at checkout out just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below